my grandfather used to tell me don't
worry about it because people with
facial hair are less evolved I want a
beard so badly I was a kid I thought I
had a chance at this
all right facial hair that I need to
shave every few days but it doesn't grow
into the point of a cool beer so it's
just a nuisance I cannot grow a beard my
father cannot grow a beard if I just
like never shave ever it'd just be like
three hairs here and here nothing here
lighter here all the hair that I would
grow on my face grows on my head
whenever I see people with beards I get
beard Envy
everyone wants what they can't have and
I can't have a beard I have some
pre-made ventilated lace pieces mustache
and beards which I apply on to the skin
and then use other hair in order to hide
all the edges let's give these dudes
some beards do I look cool yet maybe I'm
gonna look badass hmm it feels scruffy
uh it hurts it doesn't hurt at all the
people shampoo their beards hmm I
wouldn't [ __ ] with me I fear
confrontation I can tell you right now
this is not the kind of mustache I would
for all right also makes me want to rap
I don't know why my wife's worst
nightmare is this mustache I kind of
just want to smoke like a pipe or
something the pieces are actually made
out of human hair using the person whose
hair this is had a beard you think the
person whose hair this is this one's I
can join a biker gang right
whoa whoa Wow
what wait this is lesser whoa yeah Oh Oh
No
nope oh man looks kind of good it kind
of looks bad - I look like a scruffy
nerf-herder I look like I should be
bouncing a newborn baby on my lap I
could easily have my own brewery I
should be in like downtown like painting
a mural on some cool wall I look older
than 30 I don't want a beard but I also
don't want to take it off can I just
keep this on for a little bit
Sarah what do you think of my beard I
hate everything about it would you ever
make love with me again it almost makes
you feel like a different person you
know I don't think I can pull this off
I'm kind of okay seeing myself now like
it's like I'm kind of like yeah I think
I looks better without a beard
can I see myself with just the mustache
yeah let's go to shop okay
the beard the whole beard not so much
just the mustache which cool as out